hi I'm Zoe Deutsch and I'm Shea Mitchell
and we're here with BuzzFeed about to
interview each other yeah
so let's begin
okay what was your first impression of
me when we met I would say so fresh like
you're like so pretty So Fresh So bubbly
and I was like oh my God this is the
prettiest person I've ever seen I said
that to you it was really and I'm still
like oh my God you guys don't understand
like it's like there's a light bulb in
her face like she has like the pretty
there is there's light bulbs in my face
inside of it it's crazy what was the
first piece you ever bought or were
given from Tiffany's for my bat mitzvah
I was given I think it was the yeah it
was like the pocket yeah like the with
the yeah yeah which was like everything
and still is Classico strawberry I'm not
gonna do that one one I didn't even see
it okay oh interesting okay I don't know
um so you smell like holiday cookies
though just
yeah I don't know just the whole thing I
unfortunately think I smell like the
addition Hotel because I wear Noir by
lalabo and oh yes they now spray that
there so people which I think is a
beautiful scent but they smell like a
club right not ideal like there you go
she smells like the addition hotel that
was the question would you ever let me
babysit your children yes yes and I have
like instant I would definitely yeah I
go off of like feeling and Vibes for
sure you could definitely babysit my
girls love to if we switch places for a
day what would be the first thing you
would do oh my God I'm so curious how
you have enough time in the day like you
do so many things and and in so many
different worlds too to be able to turn
things off and compartmentalize and then
go to this next thing and then be a mom
and then run this business and run that
businessman act and then do an interview
and then go to a fact like you just do
so many different things
yeah I would just try to survive I don't
know
um have a couple of your ones okay all
right no I think it would be really
interesting like a learning experience
what was the worst date you ever went on
I don't know if I've ever had uh I think
just a boring conversation I try and
like inject humor and like jokes
whenever I can especially in those
situations but like when it's just a
flat line it's very difficult it was
just a boring conversation but I got out
of it really quick I also love an
awkward situation like I love awkward
moments I do too so I sat in it and
enjoyed it but then I got bored and then
you know that like when I can't even
make it just awkward silence and I'm
just bored then it's just bad because
it's no longer a challenge it's not even
a challenge yeah I'm just get me out
what's your comfort movie like what's a
movie you've watched the most it's the
only thing I can think of is not a movie
it's love Island which I think has made
me a better person but you watch the
same season over and over but I use
spinjitz I like genuinely have never
shut off my brain in my whole life I
realized until I watched love Island
that's not a comfort movie and totally
not answering it yeah but I think it's
made me a better person because you can
actually relax you can let your brain
relax coming from somebody who meditates
every day nothing compared to love
Island like I feel feel rejuvenated yeah
yeah I know I feel you even when I was
tired after just giving birth instead of
sleeping when she was napping I was
watching Love Island no way one thousand
percent and I was more tired three and
four no I was more tired but I just
couldn't stop and like I should have
been sleeping because I was exhausted
but I just kept watching it that's the
most beautiful thing I've ever been
breastfeeding just watching It season
three is my God it's that's that's why I
started with it oh my gosh I love season
three so much okay uh but also like
Anchorman and elf in those movies
I love that
what is your favorite place to eat or
drink in New York I would say my
favorite place to drink would be the
Waverly in I think it's just super cute
there's cool little bars in there so I
would say the Waverly in and I would say
to eat Carbone what about you I would
say to drink like for a
cocktailino or whatever which is across
from from via carota and then I'd say
via corota right now is my favorite it's
really good wait what's your favorite
holiday movie I think what about you
okay Bad Santa every single year
oh my God you haven't seen it okay I
need to see it I'm gonna watch it bye
BuzzFeed thank you guys so much and uh
be sure to watch something from
Tiffany's on Amazon Prime
[Music]